two solutions agriculture in a
certain way contribute to the emission
of greenhouse gases but on the other
hand agriculture is also a means of
limiting the emissions of greenhouse
gases by having part of these  gases
buried in the
ground through specific plantations
the exchanges of views planned between
ministers will make it possible to put on the
table the exchanges of good practices
what is done in certain
member states which what can be
extended to improve the contribution
from agriculture to limiting
climate change it is in the
context of the coop 21 conference
it is above all agriculture's response
to the commitments that were made in
October last year for a
massive reduction in emissions of
greenhouse gases in 2030